- Hey, you guys buying my
stuff off my ex-wife on eBay?
- Um-Mm, no, no.
- Nope.
- Yes.
- Can you at least give back
the framed picture
of me and my niece?
- I'm sorry but I really like
the sunset in the background.
- Hey, this came.
Due to budget cuts we've let
go of our first response team.
Our insurance
providers require us
to have one weapon
on hand on hand
in case there's a break-in.
(weapon cocking)
- Whoa!
Okay, let's keep it in
a safe place until...
Well, I guess considering
the people involved,
this technically won't
be considered tragic.
♪ Oh, we got it made
♪ We got it made
♪ Yeah, nothings
gonna get us down
♪ No way
♪ Everything's
perfect 'cause baby
♪ We've got it made
- Okay, since I'm the
hero, I get the gun.
But I brought ya'll in
weapons of your own.
Anita, you get nunchuks.
- In the name of the Virgin
Mary's sweet untouched titty's.
I don't want that Joy
Luck Club shit, nigga!
- More like, Out of Luck Club.
C'mon, the pun makes
it less racist.
- Well, what did you bring me?
- Two issues of Redbook,
wrapped in a spooky biker chain.
- Now, I'm not sure if
this is going to help me
with the fighting of the people.
But I am interested
in which sundresses
are flattering on oval-shaped
women, so thank you.
- How 'bout me?
- A Jafar mask.
- I should get the gun.
- Why?
- I'm a Pisces.
- That's not a thing.
- OJ was innocent.
- Thank you, Anita.
But no one should get the gun.
You're all emotionally unstable,
I've walked in on at least three
of you crying, since Monday it--
- I get emotional during Lent.
What'd you give up for
our Lord and Savior,
you Elijah Wood-looking
Mother Fucker.
- Ladies, ladies.
There's only one rational
way to settle this gunfight.
- What's that?
- Knife fight.
Okay, whoever draws
blood first wins.
- Lyle's already bleeding.
- Stop making fun of me.
- Why don't you
just share the gun.
Everybody gets it
for a half an hour.
- [Group] Ohhhhhh.
- Well, who get's the gun first?
- Well, only one
way to find out.
- What is that?
- Knife fight.
- [Group] Oh, ah, eh, oh, ouch.
- Butter-Nofs!
- It was either that
or Crazy Straws.
They don't trust us
with the real stuff
they'll be trading
us cash to be racist.
(crunching)
Hey, what was that?
- I put the gun in
the trash compactor.
Why, because most of you
would end up shooting me.
Except for Lyle, who would
probably just kill himself.
- Fingers crossed.
- Bummer, you know what?
We don't need a gun.
This is our museum,
we can remove any
obstacle in our path.
- [Group] Yeah, yes,
whooo, dee dee do.
- We're the good guys, guys.
- [Group] Whoo, Yoo hoo.
- From now on, we
become the guards
we were always meant to be!
- [Group] Yeah, yes,
yeah, mother fucker.
(snoring)
- Wow, what a sunset!
All right, back to robbin'.
♪ We got it made
♪ Nothing's gonna get us down
♪ No way
♪ Everything's perfect